after the end of the Korean War North
Korea was a virtually cashless society
everyone worked for the state and was
provided for by the state and in the
communist bloc context of the day it
worked
in 1989 North Koreans were more than
twice as wealthy as their comrades in
China now we think of them as a hermit
King and not trading very much William
Brown spent his career analyzing North
Korea for the CIA but actually they were
integrated reasonably well into the
Soviet planned system of countries the
loss of support from the Soviet Union
after its collapsed in 1991 and a series
of droughts and floods led to a great
famine in North Korea the famine
pretty much ended the public
distribution system in which the North
Korean state fed everybody through the
ration system and the government
couldn't supply food so people launched
off on their own since then a strange
hybrid economy has emerged part
government controlled where rations are
allocated by the state in part gray
market where currency is earned in the
market economy for example a textile
worker in the state-run Pyongyang
textile mill earns around 3,000 won per
month which has a street value of about
40 cents but that worker pays nothing
for housing or utilities and receives
food rations her sister might legally
work for an export-oriented company
she's allowed to get 30,000 won per
month but with fewer perks another
sister could work for a Chinese company
and earned 300 thousand won per month
but with zero perks from the government
all the state workers get paid through
this incredibly low wage system and are
dependent on rations that often show on
the ideal situation is for one person in
a family to work in the state system and
then other people in the family work out
in the marketplace and earn real money
it is a highly inefficient system in per
capita income terms North Koreans are
now eight times poorer than Chinese and
over 20 times as poor as South Koreans
rather than reform the government sought
to fill a shortfall in hard currency by
trafficking illegal goods abroad
according to numerous reports this
illegal business is run by an agency
known as office 39 it's an office that
organized principally to raise US
dollars for the ruling party a study
from a Washington based human rights
group traces the regime's criminal
ventures back to the 1970s when about a
dozen North Korean diplomats were
expelled from Scandinavian countries for
smuggling alcohol cigarettes and hashish
later the government switched to foreign
organised crime syndicates to sell
things like counterfeit pharmaceuticals
and heroin manufactured from
state-mandated poppy farms North Korea's
government has dismissed such claims and
some analysts have also questioned the
data since 2005 intercepts of North
Korean smuggling have fallen sharply
though more recently claims of cyber
theft have proliferated meanwhile Kim
jong-un has started speaking to South
Korea about opening up for investment in
restricted economic zones and he's also
talking about switching to a more China
like economic system whether that's a
true change of heart or just a tactical
retreat in the face of sanctions remains
to be seen
you